to get back to work towardsler
stepping out one more things actually
get better
but this a Chancellor still holding the
line
and sticking to the plan
Jeremy Hunt hoping to turn the country's
economic fortunes around in time for the
next general election
today a Chancellor with a spring in his
step
and this was why I report today on a
British economy which is proving the
doubters wrong
foreign
for Budget responsibility forecasts that
because of changing International
factors and the measures I take the UK
will not now enter a technical recession
this year
We are following the plan and the plan
is working
liver but still a way to go today we
deliver the next part of our plan a
budget for growth a much briefed in
advance the main thrust of it getting
away in Workforce back into jobs I don't
want any parent with a child under five
to be prevented from working if they
want to so today I announce that
ineligible households where all adults
are working at least 16 hours we will
introduce 30 hours of free child care
not just for three and four-year-olds
but for every single child over the age
of nine months that child care provision
staggered not coming in fully until 2025
working mums a portion of the population
targeted in a pre-election Splurge as
were the over 50s after I turned 50 I
was relegated to the back benches and
planned for a quiet life but instead I
decided to set an example by embarking
on a new career in fine minutes
it's going well thank you his job on
track but millions of over 50s leaving
the world of work the chancellor
offering a mighty tax break on pension
pots to entice some of them back no one
should be pushed out of the workforce
for tax reasons so today I will increase
the pension's annual tax-free allowance
by 50 percent from forty thousand to
sixty thousand
some have also asked me to increase the
lifetime allowance from its one million
pound limit
but I've decided not to do that instead
I will go further and abolish the
lifetime allowance
scrap in the limit on the lifetime
pension allowance helping the very rich
and as the corporation tax rate hike
kicks in a kicker for business with a
series of investment incentives worth
billions we will introduce a new policy
of full Capital expensing that means
that every single pound a company
invests in it equipment plant or
Machinery can be deducted in full and
immediately from taxable profits a more
familiar support remaining too the cap
on energy bills in place for another
three months and fuel Duty Frozen for
another year a nod from the PM this
government hopeful it's enough the
declinists are wrong and the optimists
are right
we we stick to the plan because the plan
is working and I commend this statement
to the house
crowd please in Chancellor a budget
backed by the front bench
but with living standards set to full
farther the opposition benches scathing
I hopelessly divided party caught
between a rock of Decline and a hard
place of their own economic recklessness
dressing up stagnation of stability as
their expiry date looms ever closer and
that's the looming election on the minds
of many and from former cabinet
Ministers of recent months concerned we
have arise now in corporation tax but we
then sort of salami slice it a bit with
some Capital allowances to pretend it's
not much of a rise this is not a good
approach to tax policy the best approach
to tax policy is low tax rates with few
exclusions many Tory MPS want tax cuts
right now but this budget was about
laying the groundwork for tax cuts to
come just in time for the next general
election the watchwords for this budget
it would grow in the economy and all of
the big measures were targeted to do
just that this is a chancellor who wants
to prove his doubters wrong but he and
the Prime Minister know all too well
that turn in disillusioned voters into
Believers once again is going to be a
very hard task
families still grappling with the
largest fall in living standards in
modern times might take little comfort
from this budget the road ahead still
Bleak Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster